[Music]
a computer programmer at verizon was
fired after it was discovered he'd been
outsourcing his job to a company in
china so he could spend his days surfing
the web
yeah i saw that story and i thought what
kind of person
tries to get away with outsourcing his
own job to asia it's insanity do you
hear about this andy
yes
you're very good mr conan
seriously where's andy do you know where
andy is sir
yankees
is andy richter do you know where andy
richter is
[Music]
okay
okay he's probably in he's in his
dressing room right do you think he's in
his dressing room i'm betting andy's in
his dressing room all right i'll be
right back hold on this is ridiculous
you can't just take that's insanity
ridiculous
stupid
huge waste of time
get rid of this crap
come on
come on andy knock it off we got to get
back to work let's go
okay who are you
mr richter uh hired me to watch cat
videos while he naps
absurd andy come on get up this is
stupid let's go
mr richter pays me to take naps for him
okay
jeff jeff do you know about all of this
han hawa
all right so now what am i supposed to
do
what
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dave franco
[Applause]
no straight jackets
wheels okay um
me